pleasure to have you on the show Joseph
allanté if anyone hasn't seen The
Apprentice then they're missing out
who's a great show and I was watching
The Apprentice was it last year you you
you won The Apprentice 2015 buddy
no it wasn't 2015 on the TV that's what
I want to know when they actually go
you're tired so we actually started
filming for that on April the 26th 2015
was when I went away to the crazy
absolutely tell you God's honest truth
when I was watching I was rooting for
you and I told you that well you know
when we when we first when we first
started chatting and stuff when we first
met but I was I was rooting for you and
I was so glad to see you win because you
were just clearly the best contestant
thank you very much obviously should
have thought that you go on to do great
things great things both in terms of
business and in terms of also helping
others being prepared to put yourself
out there sometimes when people do well
they hide away and you don't hear from
them but you actually talk openly freely
put yourself out there so uh that's
absolutely excellent so to talk to me a
little bit about the beginning so for
anyone that wants to know like the
background like how did you get started
business what's your story I was
expelled from school when I was 15 years
of age and I actually went and did a
plumbing apprenticeship I didn't have
anything to do with my time and my
approach to local plumber and I said
look instead of going to school can I
come and work you for free for years and
when you went on 16 you start paying me
and put me into college
and that's exactly what he did and
that's how I entered the plumbing and
heating industries I was able to excel
very quickly through the plumbing and
heating industry qualified plumber 18
qualified a gas engineer at 19 and then
by the time I hit 22
and I was servicing and repairing
boilers every single day and I thought
is this what the rest of my life is
going to be like like many people
probably in employment they have reach a
level and then it just becomes the same
so at the age of 22 and was when I
decided to start my first business and
that was in Prague ask the one that I
took on to the show and the one that I
built national and I started that
funnily enough off the back of reading
Lord Sugar's autobiography for Christmas
my mum bought me for Christmas
basically I was 21 I just got back from
Australia I've been living there for a
year and I came back got back into the
same job and then over that year in 2011
between Christmas and New Year's I was a
bit demotivated I was doing the same
thing and I needed some inspiration my
mum got me Lord Sugar's autobiography
which was this one which I've got here
what you see is what you get and I
hadn't read a book for many many years
probably since like year six but there
wasn't a self educator at 22 I wasn't
into personal development or anything
like that so I read his books I was am
an apprentice fan and over that two-week
period I saw how someone in the person
someone in one lifetime was able to
create billionaire wealth coming from
accounting state and a poor background I
didn't come from accountants I came I
saw his journey and it made me think
that if this guy can do it then so can i
I couldn't see anything that he had that
I wasn't able to replicate so at the end
of that two-week period I literally quit
my job and took out a 15,000 pound loans
from Tesco's and it was a home
improvement so I was getting about 50
grand a year at 21 for the job that I
was doing it was a home improvement loan
no business plan no idea of how I was
gonna start but it was so motivating so
fired up that I knew that I was
committing and whatever was gonna happen
I was going to succeed to get this 15
grand loan what a 1500 pound van
branded impre gas and then I bought a
500 pound suit and I hit the high
streets in the property management
market and started trying to sell to
estate agents to take their manes
in Egypt that's how I got started in
business that's so cool and you know
what's really interesting I don't think
I've ever told you this before but when
I was at the school I wanted to be my
dream job was a plumber was it that was
my dream job and then I decided I didn't
want to be a plumber after I went to get
to property thing I've not told you
about me as well I actually I don't know
what year cuz you know how terrible I
move timescales remembering when things
happens but I actually applied to be on
the apprentice and was turned down might
have been about 20 I suspect but so um
so you I mean just the fact that you
were 21 and in 50-round a year after
being did you say you expelled from
school yeah that I mean are you born to
achieve a lot more than that but just
being on a fifty grand a year paper at
21 after being kicked out of school that
out in his own right is a big
achievement because most 21 year olds on
50 grand I know and you know when when I
was expelled everybody wrote me off you
know and to get so I got to give lots of
value to the audience and know I was in
a position where and come from a poor
background a mum worked three jobs the
three-pound an hour doing clean and my
dad was an alcoholic unemployed bum
didn't work I don't see him or speak to
him now and I haven't since I was 13 but
he didn't work and you know I didn't
have any inspiration any motivation
really but then when I got expelled I
realized that I was on my own
I realized that my circumstances I was
making excuses as to why I was acting up
why I was being bad I was blaming him I
was blaming my background nose blaming
the teachers I was blaming everybody and
I realized that if I wanted to change my
life
I had to take control of it the Calvary
the cavalry weren't coming to save me no
one was coming to save me everybody had
given up on me no one was going to help
me and I had to decide to make a
decision
to change and that's exactly what I did
you know and I always I've always felt
that I was destined for something
special unless my aim in life is to
create legacy that last 1,000 years when
I'm gone and I knew that I could do it I
knew that I wasn't an idiot and I was
only bad because of my circumstances but
I knew I could change it and I decided
then that was gonna go to war on my
career and that's when I got into
plumbing and just excelled so quickly
through the ranks and you know it's a
good it's a good job for people that 50
grand a year that's a fairly decent
that's why well it's become a blonde
line use as a point was good money I
knew that I wasn't a super educated
person doing that and that's exactly
kinda why I started the guy that was I
went and did the apprenticeship with was
25 we drove a BMW he had a pretty
girlfriend wanted to be like him yeah
and everybody said that plumbers made 50
quid an hour you know and you know
probably similar by the sounds of things
to where you grew up no the mates that I
had it wasn't a lot of motivation people
weren't wanting to be worth wanting to
take over the world you know going into
a labouring job after school was like
the best thing you could do to get 50
quid a day and being a plumber was like
the next level up that was like huge so
the people that I knew that worked in
supermarkets and so on so you know it
seemed what the one to go for and it has
changed my life you know I know a lot to
that industry yeah yeah that's really
cool so you said that your mom got you
the book Lord sure yeah how old were you
when that happened 21 or 22 you've got
to give you hats off to your mum for
that because she kind of although she
was their cleaner and wasn't a wealthy
successful businesswoman herself the
fact that she got you that but why do
you think she got you the book you know
what it's like when parents run out of
ideas to get your presents when you're
older they don't really know what to get
it's like well I still get some pants
and here's a book you know but at the
same time Sam I've always been a man
apprentice fan but a bit obsessed with
it since the very first series
when Tim Campbell won when it was on
bbc2 hoster watch it I used to vision
from the early days you know when the
Gherkin was on there you know I was a
village boy I was from a village and I
wanted the big city like it just used to
excite me so much where they used to
slide the black the doors open and get
out in the suits but that was that was
what I wanted for my life so each series
I always get on smash these people to
pieces you know I can absolutely boss
this out I'm a leader I can win this no
problem she knew I was obsessed with
there and nothing that's why she got it
about how you got on and stuff so what
what was the application process light
did you think you were gonna get
accepted onto the show like talk about
that and what made you what what really
made you do it
okay so first question a way you said
did you think I was gonna get on a lot
of people say to me did I think I was
gonna win it and my answer is all of
course like what I was gonna win it
nobody enters into a competition if they
don't think they can win or they might
do and that's why they don't win right
so first and foremost yes I want hundred
percent knew that I was gonna win and
you have to think try that if you want
to succeed right even if you don't win
you have to think that you can't be
thinking not absent well I might win no
I'm gonna win 100% so yes I thought I
would get on the chokes and yes I knew
that I was going to win because every
time I enter a competition happening but
the application process so let me tell
you a little bit how strange this all is
so I've been in business for three years
I was 25 when I applied I was doing
about half a million a year in revenue I
had I had seven plumbers working for me
and a small office I was running
everything from my mind like we were a
good little business 3,000 homes on
contract and I had leveled off in my
business career I'd hit my ceiling I was
25 and I know about business
plumbing business I wanted to grow a
needed mentorship I needed tasks I
wanted exposure one of the world and
then I came in on January than I'm into
my house that I had at the time got
Facebook up and it said the last call
for the apprentice 24 hours to apply and
at that very moment I'm very a very
spiritual I believe a lot in the law of
attraction in the universe and I always
looking for signs to confirm that this
the right move for me to take things and
I knew that that was my opportunity I
knew that that was my calling because I
was just feeling like I leveled off and
didn't know what to do next and so I
applied to go on and then going accepted
which is incredible
you know a lot of people say about the
application process what did you say
how did you act you know I said I wanted
to be the godfather of business my
Clojure going off we cannot refuse my
one of my people that I admired was Hugh
Hefner I wanted to be a playboy I wanted
to go some clothes and money you know
all of these things are what they
brought up on the show laughter maybe
that's why they accepted you got to say
those things right because number one at
the time I kind of believed it I was 25
years old and single and I was doing
quite well and I liked that lifestyle
and I wanted to be rich and famous and
have cars and houses pretty girlfriends
that was just how I for that time and
are you always you know and I always
think it's important to get noticed
you've got to stand out so I have sweep
that simple and people don't like that
but the reality is it's true I mean if
you want to be seen you've got to be
prepared to do things that other people
aren't and you know that's making an
impact for make a statement or whatever
it may be
Joseph do you think that they like that
thing because if they have people with a
big ego it's more entertaining for the
viewer to watch them people then get
crushed without a doubt yeah you're not
gonna go on there saying listen or I let
my actions do the talking
you'd never get accepted yeah you're not
gonna write any obligation well now I
let my actions speak for me but then
they say oh you not quite you know
you've gotta once you got to understand
what game you're playing in life
everything is a game right and you're
going to understand what the rules of
the game are yeah if you want to apply
to get on a competition like that what
the rules that again why will they need
to see Who I am and I need to make these
statements I need to make them believe
I'm gonna be entertaining I need to give
them prove into that records of what I'd
done something I'm gonna be successful I
need to create myself with their ideal
profile so they choose me there's 60,000
people applying for this stuff so how do
you get in there if you're not unique
right so always understand the game that
you're in and then it's the same one
you've got on the show you know there
were certain things you know that you
work that you'd there's no there's no
fake recording but you know you
understand what type of what type of
attitude you need for the producers you
understand what the kind of things they
want you to say you need to understand
how you need to act you know and they
have their way of editing and filming so
if you can master what they need and do
it for them your double play in the game
um and that's the skill that people need
to be able to master you know and and
that helps and that helped me you know
and I was able to do it but I was very
very true to myself I was very straight
I was very open I was very honest one of
the things you didn't do in the
apprentice you didn't like badmouth
everybody you didn't come across
arrogant at all I didn't think on the
actual show yeah and you know what I
think everybody was kind of shocked by
that because it's the way that I looked
back then and could do the things about
Hugh Hefner people thought that I was a
showboater that couldn't back it up
didn't Lord Sugar make you shave off
your moustache yeah well he didn't make
me but this is where this is where I'm
smart right so they kept talking about
the matando mister
and actually I lost the property tasks
because we were selling high-end
apartments and I went to this estate
agent in London and I was like yeah 1 4
% selling your property I'm the best
salesman out there are all absolutely
smashes and he gave it to Richard and
varnas and to be honest I know why I did
because they're much more well-spoken
than I am and he probably bought they
were better represented in his type of
properties than me even though I sold in
quarter of a million won in scrap for
three-quarters of a million apartment on
that day and that sort in that task
there but what was my point and so that
one he said look you were too young you
jumped in you were saying too many
stupid things about getting higher
Commission and everything else and then
we went to me and then I got through
that and the next task was the
interviews so I knew they wanted me to
change my image and I knew right that if
they could tell the story to the viewers
this round you know when he come in as a
bit of a joker but you actually backed
up what he did but the apprentice molded
him into this really slob looking
businessman that I was gonna play that
storyline for them right so I went on
that night I said to the producer Lister
I'm gonna shave my moustache off in the
morning come and capture this because
this is a piece so that's exactly what I
did and then I went looking like this
whether I was much lost was really sharp
then in the early stages I look like a
different character and he just absolute
blinded story listen so you won right
how do you feel when you won was it like
a massive deal what was the experience
like when you got when Lord Sugar said
that you went to bind to you the most
proudest thing for me out of the whole
experience when you get Wendy when it
gets to nails because you don't know
until the day that your only your ID
show who wins they like announce it like
a few hours before and then they put and
then it gets played out yeah and you're
in a room and you're away from your
family and they take the phone and then
I walk out on the stage and Jackie was
there Lord Sugar never sitting there
under your hide shots and then walk
through it I just remember that and I
just walked through right strided fruits
and a clock yeah
in the corner my mum sitting in the
front row tears streaming down her face
because when I was expelled at 15 we
walked out the Headmaster's office and
she cried and she was like what the hell
are you gonna do now you've ruined your
life because she thought it was the end
of the world for me and I stood to that
day listen don't worry I'm gonna make
you proud again one day
and then this 10 years like fast forward
10 years I just caught her eyes I love
that woman to pieces I caught her eye
and she was crying but smiling no yes
I've done it like I made her happy so
and that was a pretty awesome moment
incredible and but the wind was a little
bit surreal it was more confirmation but
I wasn't nuts thinking that I could pull
it off and I actually pulled it off so I
think that's a very big lesson for a lot
of people your first major success can
be you know a lot of people think they
get successful first time because they
get lucky but actually that first
connection means that you prove to
yourself what you're capable of and then
you should be able to then replicate
that without continuing to question say
this in property you've probably heard
me say it that your first deals always
your hardest deal because we first feel
maybe a property deal or a business deal
suddenly the confidence that it gives
you you can just then duplicate and do
it again and again and again and I guess
it's the same when like you wouldn't you
win the apprentice that feeling of
winning if you as long as you keep
putting the work in the momentum of
winning once you got that in your side
just means you're just gonna keep
winning keep winning keep winning
success breeds more success I don't
disagree and you know and that was good
and that was good and then the next
thing though Sam which was probably a
bit strange was you get that high with
them followed by quite a big low and you
know you win and it's amazing people
watch that show a week and you know I
was walking in the street everyone in
pictures and everything else and you
know you're just in this new life it was
it was amazing I was getting by it all
these super
dues and events in London it was
incredible your MTA's and bits and bobs
that was I just loved that environment I
was 25 and I loved it even more but then
you're like wow reality kicks in and
then I have to go back and run a
plumbing business and I never went on
that show to try and be a reality TV
star I went in to be a businessman and
to learn so I know that learning
business is sustainable for life 15
minutes of fame comes and goes like many
had and if you don't learn anything else
it's down to you drop off the face of a
cliff and then you're you know back into
original I forget so I knew that it was
the right thing to do but it was also
very difficult to just go back to normal
like just go back to work and then you
know the interviews were still good but
it was dropping down and you know then
you like just like you don't you're not
you're not in demand anymore so I
thought that a very strange thing to
handle you know you look good Tyson Fury
he talks about how he Klitschko's you
know he spent his whole life winning the
world titles and then after he beat him
exact whoa what's next yeah what more
can I do
and it was an my story's a little
version of that really on at that moment
because of the apprentice for me with
everything it was like my winning my
World Cup winning my world title and
then it goes and you're like wow I need
to feel that buzz again yeah then I'll
from that moment I went on a mission to
try and feed myself with more more
achievements Ford book podcasts like
anything I could get that would get me
recognition that was almost an
unachievable task and I still kind of
feel that way now you know I don't want
to skip too far heads you might have
some questions but at the moment man I
need to set my sights so big because if
I don't I I I get really depressed I
don't know maybe you're the same if you
don't have like you're not moving
forward in business or you're not doing
deals or you're not you know it's hard
to take to just be normal anymore
and try and live like a content life I
really struggle with that
I haven't so big and and I always say
that why don't always say actually I say
really but I strongly believe and I say
to my close people my friends and family
but actually the more successful you get
them all only yeah and yeah the SAS is
obviously good but actually without
significance you're going to be left
pretty empty because you're gonna hit
the goal and it's like and then what
it's the reason why astronauts when they
go to space they get back and they're
absolutely pressed because there's no
higher place to go from that whereas I
feel that that when it's about you when
it's about all about me I want to win
the apprentice I want to get a million
in my bank all I want to get you hit it
and it's not actually nothing's changed
others and it's about significance that
that gives it a different type of
contentment and I think that's what you
find it now that's the reason you're on
this show right now inmate you found
that in sharing and in speaking and in
writing books and podcasts and actually
sharing your story then you were doing
what Lord Sugar's done Lord Sugar become
very very successful I'm sure that he
does the apprentice I'm sure he does it
not for the money I'm sure he does it
because he the significance and the
fulfillment I mean I don't know but I
bet that's why and and people ask me all
the time if you're so successful in
property then why do you teach others
and it's like you're actually missing
the point because when money's no object
anymore then you've got to do something
you know you're figuring out yeah I've
always been like one to try and scour my
friends and family and gifts because
you're right money but money is easy
come easy go and it's easy to make and
you know the better card you buy the
better the apartment that you get about
holidays you go and that's all great but
it is empty and giving back is where the
enjoyment is and and teaching others you
know I am so blessed and pleased that
I'm entering into this personal
development works because I didn't feel
fulfilled being the CEO of a National
Boy installation business it just wasn't
what I was sent to the finish the story
of the business I think a lot what
you're doing now a new year right great
charity stuff as well which we can talk
about you've written a book you've been
in Forbes magazine
a business so you you got it to a point
where you were doing very well but you
needed to scale it
you teamed up with with Lord Sugar he um
he bought into the business yeah you
know you think about me starting the
business of the back of reading his book
three years later I sold him half of it
for a quarter of a million quid that's
insane that's insane
[Music]
Masek I just says well I know
statistically massive respect man and
congratulations on that because peopie i
tried i poured for the apprentice and
got turned down you got accepted and
then won it that's a massive achievement
and honestly like i think you just did
so well on that show so you don't grew
the business called sugar for a couple
few years you danced the business back
to back to Lord Sugar so we were in
business for about two years we got it
to a million a year by year and a half
go to a million a year and I wanted to
go national and I would push on beating
the drum for growth right they wanted me
to go a lot slower and they were pulling
me back every board meeting no you don't
want to grow this quickly and I was said
to them you know they got to a point
where the board meeting became very
challenging very difficult it was a bit
negative it was negative for me you know
I buy at 27 28 years of our age wanting
to create and a business that was going
to take over the world you know I was
obsessed with sugar story have been
Amstrad and you know how we built it and
I know these smashed it in his late 20s
right so I wanted to be like that so to
go and be told that I need to go slow
and now the little climbing business was
not what I wanted to hear wherever it
was a right or wrong information I
didn't want it I didn't want to be in
plumbing forever I wanted to grow
quickly and exit right and get out so I
could go into the world that I mean now
that's what I would send to do so I said
to them one day listen I don't like he
coming here and you keep saying to me
slow down I want to risk everything that
we've got and go for it
if we bust we bust right but if we win
we win that's what I'm prepared to do I
understand that you want me to stay
quiet in the back
so each year you can parade me and say
that he's made a little bit of profit
and blah blah blah
but I'm not nor to his business partner
I'm Joseph Valenti
I've got my own brand and you always
gonna be in the guy's shadow yeah
massive respect to him and I'm so
grateful for what he did for me but I
never wanted to be in his shadow
I want to carve my own path so I always
knew that as well we're gonna be
difficult so I said look I understand
where you are coming from I've come if
I'm gonna grow this rapidly it's risk
with rapid growth and you don't want to
keep pumping money into the business and
so on but I want to grow it that way and
I'm prepared to put my name on the line
to do that so if you're not on the front
line with me Brian you don't want to do
it this way they let me buy you out and
I will go it alone and we will part ways
and then you'll say thank you say thank
you I'll say thank you you say good luck
and then anything that bad happens is on
my head yeah and then he said look
respect I understand where you're coming
from
we did a deal and I negotiated it and I
got out and you know what everybody said
it's about risk and reward and you got a
big bollocks
right in business you really really have
you got our big balls you got to make
big moves and I was 27 at the time yeah
two years ago I won the apprentice and
now I was making a move to go on my own
the first apprentice to ever do this
right and to buy him out and go and go
on his own you know I'm not gonna tell
my staff that I've done it and they you
know imagine what the pressor thinking
of people on the outside and you hate
was scary it really really was but I
wanted this more so I was prepared to
make the jump so you know the lesson is
the people you've got to do big things
if you want them if you want to have big
wins and you've got to be brave when you
got an imposing you've got it going for
it and I bought him out a million a year
and when I exited the business we did a
million in a month that was our best
month on record and that was only a year
and a half later so I went on to scale
it nationally by myself I had a hundred
and fifty people in the company in 2019
we won national installer of the year
beating British Gas I'd launched in
Scotland I'd launched in Cardiff
launched in every major city in the UK
in Great Britain sorry knock knock
Norman
Island and we were you know we built a
massive company now we got to a point
where we've gone through rapid growth
the options the options for me were to
get investment to keep funding it we
were acquiring BG that's how big would
God without them fun without the funding
so it was all we've got to a point where
it was a risky business anyway because
we've got so big with no additional
support
everything was so tight at that level I
mean it's a very low margin industry as
well you know know the lesson that I
learned it's always go off the big
margin business you have to put the same
18 hours in whether you make him one um
percent or a hundred percent right
you've got to put the same time into
picture pick your pick your products
correctly and it was a low margin in of
challenges so we did well him know them
but this assembly took a massive hit in
sales in December nineteen hard the
sales white-tie cashflow al Gregg's it
hits as hard the winters are getting
warmer and we were all and we would
direct sales on a national sales team
that would go outs it leads and then
sell boilers if the lead Strider we had
no recurring revenue in the business and
we didn't have big reserves so it puts
up massive risk so I had to do a very
quick sale with a company called REO
capital which is like a an investment
recovery firm that had deeper pockets
and funding to the business but to be
honest when we won national installers
and this what I say to everybody that
I'm coaching have your goal and stick to
it have a plan and get out when your
time is your time don't go beyond that
and and be brave enough to know when to
move on because sometimes you know these
things are holding you from these things
smaller things and when we want national
install and I put my first man has
gotten I actually fell this like whole
wave of energy drained from my body and
I was like [ __ ] I've done what I sow to
do seven years ago because it the
beginning when I had that van I could
never think about with a national
business I was done I wasn't just in
business for money I do what I do for my
own personal success and ambition
achievements in my mind and well
we hit national I was done I didn't want
to stay it anymore I didn't want to try
and make millions out of the business
millions I wanted to move on I was done
and you know as much as it was a
negative that we had to sell very
quickly it actually released me from
prison that I'd created in this business
yeah 18 hours a day seven days a week
managing our business without doing 50
people in ain't a good life right and
especially one in a tight business tight
industry at an industry that you don't
really our passion for anymore
you know I didn't wanna sell boilers so
he actually created an opportunity for
me to get out you know and I was like
wow this is incredible
so yeah that's really interesting so
basically you got you grew the business
to a nice healthy amount you then teamed
up with Lord Sugar he bought and you
scaled massively yeah we'll brought him
out and set up on your own you then
scaled massively masked me again you had
such a big growth that your your profit
margins weren't great you were relying
on recurring income your overhead to a
massive then look there you weren't
enjoying it you hit the goals you wanted
to hear and then you just felt like
actually you know what I'm not enjoying
this anymore
it's stressful and you sold so now what
are you doing now so go out in January
and then I instantly started up a
coaching business in the construction
space because there's no one doing
personal development in the coaching in
construction so my aim it might be
against plumbers start plumbing
businesses electricians start electrical
businesses builders build houses but
nobody's teaching you how to run a
business
right I was a plumber that was ambitious
no one taught me how to run a business I
made so many mistakes wasted so much
money right but I was lucky enough so
learn from some top people you know last
year I had I had the Cigna former
managing director of British Gas is my
personal advisor he was what he retired
and he was watching me on LinkedIn and
came to me and said I can help you in
write any 162 he ran them at 540 million
a year hundred thousand installations
and I was paying him a lot of money to
teach me and add sugar and alone of
others so some great mentors and
which basically turned me into a
businessman because how do you go from
one man in a van a plumber
that wasn't educated really in academic
li that just learned climbing edges
qualification to being a CEO running a
team of senior managers at run a team of
mid-level managers a team of employees
running a national operation doing 500
installs nationally with a huge supply
chain and all of that was on me so I've
learned some skills so I can help so
many here and teach these guys are
ambitious because the one-man bands
usually you're only there cuz they
haven't got a clue to how they want to
grow so I can show them how to grow
scout it up to 30,000 a month in four
weeks when recurring revenue excellent
great profit margins much better
lifestyle so much less stress and I've
been doing that for the last couple of
months and that's going great and now
I've launched so I know obviously um
I've been watching your journey and I
know you're smashing it in the availab
space and so on so I launched an immense
business on the day they basically shut
they said stop matic average we we were
going to do business boot camps where it
was a general training and then offer
the opportunity to come on to our
advanced training at the end so
three-day training yeah and then we
organized our first event in London in
March the 12 2004 whatever the date was
in South Bank hundred and 50 businesses
confirmed and only twelve showed up it
was a disaster the night before they
stopped all Premier League game they
shut the pubs down so nobody came really
but we still managed to do quite a good
event and I put it on and we did
actually show some courses and starts
but the last two three weeks I've been
in lockdown now what we've been in it
now five six weeks the first two weeks
in lockdown of demotivated I'm still
running my coaching business we put on
zoo so it wasn't desperate for money or
time I don't like sitting around so I
was like right what what's the future
look like here to forget about thinking
that in two weeks or eight weeks I'm
going to go back and do this event
business again that I really want to do
right now is done to a level yeah
going to come back but you know launch
online start selling free webinars you
know and create something and then how
to succeed came out of a brainstorming
session and of what we can sell sells
courses we can sell coaching courses we
can sell how to launch a podcast courses
you know people will buy this stuff
because they're in their homes and it's
adding so much value to the marketplace
right now so I've done that and launched
a few webinars you know and it's been
quite successful so just hopefully
really excited about growing that really
is where I'm currently I have that stuff
you love that stuff love it love it your
property is one you got property talk
about how we met cuz I think you've been
following my journey for a while you've
been watching my property videos yeah
forget it so I'll be watching you online
I mean I member seeing you about four or
five years ago actually yeah I used to
see that oh I see that one way you hold
the they buy low rent high book yeah
yeah I always used to see that coming up
on my facebook now we probably got three
or four years ago you promised you won
the apprentice then you probably start
watching me and I just didn't know yeah
exactly so yeah so yeah I mean I had a
rent to read business for a while when
it was younger we're about five
properties on there that kind of film to
the wayside when I was growing in gasps
grown a multimillion-pound company
having five I'd said to you the other
day when we spoke I think one of the
biggest things that I regret and I don't
like to say regret but I do think back
and think what would have happened if
I'd have gone into property and where
I'd be right now not that I'm not
grateful where I am because I'm the
journey and I wouldn't have had the
apprentice or the brand so I I think you
know where I would have been because it
all honestly I started the property
people about three - about four to five
months before I applied to the
apprentice and when I got because I was
gonna sack off in free gas you know
honestly cuz you're 24 I didn't want to
be a plumber anymore I've got it - quite
a big level and I hated running the
business he's a hard business to run
right people
into people's houses and they need to be
multi-skilled and they can damage things
and it's low margin and they're so much
manual operation in supply chain to run
it was such a challenging business very
very stressful the I was gonna quit it
and go into property I only stayed in it
because of the apprentice and then after
that I had a point to prove so I stay
any longer and longer and longer you
know I would have got out sooner if just
followed my journey on the property
stuff before the apprentice would you be
richer or poorer now I think I'd be
richer but it probably wouldn't have the
brand yeah you definitely would have got
the Forbes I would obviously wouldn't
have got the apprentice of wouldn't
about a billionaire business partner I
wouldn't have met a lot of the people
that I met do you know what Umbra gas
was hell right running that company and
it was like in second levels of I look
back and still don't realize how the
hell I put my phone through that rapid
growth in what we did cause it isn't
manufacture we just make a computer
whack in PC world and then you can sell
millions and it's repeat it was so many
people involved in that operation how we
put it together so quickly it nearly
killed me
yeah the company still burning it's
improving oh yeah I sold it on so we
sold them we sold out at the brand the
access intellectual I like when you you
know when I don't know if you've
experienced this but your alarm your
morning alarm and then when you hit when
you hear the sound it kind of gives you
like a feeling I don't have that anymore
relate to it back in the day when I was
like at school but yeah when you see if
you saw like a van Gogh past the Emperor
in progress
Impa gas would you kind of get that
feeling or would you think wow legacy I
started that and feel we proud
definitely number two good thank my
lucky stars are not running it anymore
you know you've got to think the own new
owners must be going through hell they
bought it off me and then they went
straight into Corona like I'd be under
vez breakdowns right if we were I know
what it was like when we had a big bad
month in December it we kind of wipers
out almost you know I put a deer and no
one's died good
probably just got some loans out and
they're just thinking long time ya know
without a doubt they are yeah and then a
furlough just stop and stuff could this
shut down for a short period but you
know I wouldn't have had that money all
that time so I'm just so glad that I got
out when I did them you know I think
being good at business isn't is you're
all about timing
you know and it's having that view and
that vision into the future of knowing
when things are necessarily not going to
work I looked at the industry I looked
at the landscape I looked at how it was
changing I looked at the business models
where people were selling them online
and people were self surveying and it
was causing you know people were jumping
on that but it was wiping the margins
we're gonna take it out anyway in 24
months really cuz there was just no
money left in the game you actually just
get your tights or entire to untie it so
um I'm glad I pulled it off and I did
you know and all over again from scratch
right now with the black but the
knowledge and the experience you've got
but we've no money what would you do
passion or development what have a do
purse isn't personal development
something that you do in a business or
alongside sorry sorry teach and teach
personal development why do you love
teaching so much
just I just love helping me do you know
the reason being yeah you're in a
business where people will come to you
and they're gonna say you know I've
learned this and it's amazing I'm in a
bit I was in a business where people are
ringing up because they're boiling a
bust and they have no money right so you
were you're in that yeah and it's a
negative buoyant experience yeah you're
able to teach right because you've got a
story right now I've been there done
that got the t-shirt you start a
business you've had values about
mistakes you've got successes you've
been in Forbes you've made millions of
money millions of pounds you've teamed
up you've had business advice from Lord
Sugar so you're able to do that but if
you starting again from scratch you have
the experience let's say you didn't have
the brand or you didn't have the proven
track records let's say because not
everyone can just do that if someone
just started up a training company from
like right now we've no with no
backstory then then sorry I thought you
said if I had the backstory that change
my question from scratch but you knew
what you know but you didn't have the
brand you didn't have the
[Music]
maybe if it wasn't personal development
it would be property and if it wasn't
property it might be finance what we're
doing finance as in brokering finance
okay I think any better I think probably
stick with that yeah yeah I mean I want
to go I want it I do want to go big into
property development I'm growing my
business and I want to start putting
profits into property and I want us to
grow that as well an investment we also
have a mutual connection with Grant
Cardone I don't know if you know him
personally but I know you all you were
the 10x I don't know person eeper we've
exchanged a lot of messages on insta and
I met and I went to Vegas in January as
did the diamond ticket so we did the
meet and greet and they had a private
party with his hangar in the jet and
Rick Ross's that was pretty cool advice
you've had off of like Lord Sugar
compared the way that Grant Cardone
teachers is different Grande Cod don'ts
my type of guy in terms of style Lord
was just very fun and brutal and yeah
every time you get in an ass-kicking
even if you do something good getting an
ass-kicking like it was it wasn't a
positive it wasn't a necessarily a
motivate he's not a motivating guy you
know I'm not bad-mouthing him but look
at his Twitter
it's just negativity after negativity
he's always pulling out Morgan or
calling someone at work you know there's
no positive statements come in from that
Twitter feed I can't do that it just
drains me I want that negativity so you
know I want to be round somebody lets
you know look took a story in a badass
right I respect him so much of I always
love them regardless of whether we split
or what happened right I always loved
him because of respect I didn't like him
and he knows I didn't like him I don't
like him but I respected him yes the
difference yeah Cardone I respect and I
like him I like I just like his style
because he's motivated he makes me feel
good you get your energy built up
there's a guy that makes mood so you
know it's a much better way of teaching
and yeah this is a person who I do a lot
of self assessment and you know people
in my business in him from saying that
you know for a lot for a while I would
you complete wanker right I once I was
that guy that was walking around I would
be shout at people all the time yeah I
ran things military you know people were
scared to approach me and they get
bollock in you know I remember thinking
at about 28 29 this isn't how I want to
be perceived and this isn't how I want
to support and help people and I
literally flipped my style to where I
wouldn't shout anymore you know I was so
trying to find the positive in
everything you know because I was big
enough to know that I was gonna be like
sugar and people were scared to approach
him you know I saw in the board meetings
it struck most trusted advisors and
scared of it they shake when they retire
and talk to I don't want that so you
know I made a conscious effort to change
my style where I was motivating where I
was supporting where I gave help don't
get me wrong
and people cross me and they're taking
the piss then they're gonna feel the
wrath but you know you've got to I
wanted to be seen as a much more
positive figure rather than the guy that
they were scared to knock on the door
does that make sense you know I I'm I'm
the same as you on this one my staff of
there aren't scared of me in the
slightest they're very I'm quite
approachable we chat we note about them
I kind of see as I'm there to say I work
for my staff as much my job is to serve
them and to support them I mean
obviously I'd never criticize Lord Sugar
because he's very very successful and I
respect him as well grand Cod the thing
is that I guess where I was going that
is the grand Cardone like one of the
things that you said was that you said
that Lord Sugar was telling you to keep
it smaller and you wanted to scale it
and he was yeah small and you were
thinking but that's probably not where
he would be but he's making
me do that don't would definitely not
giving you that advice he'd be saying
that M X 10x that's kind of where I'm
getting at the thing is everybody
there's one thing I've learned in my
time
is everybody has an agenda right and
everybody's agenda is different to
everybody else's agenda but and their
agenda was that they wanted to keep the
Wynn small and that you go every year
and you say you're doing well and they
don't want risk why would he want
aggravation and to grow a National Board
of installation business when he's a
billionaire why would he want that risk
he doesn't want it right wants you to
play the part of his story
yeah and that that's understandable I
get it I understand his agenda
you ain't gonna want someone at the back
end come on it's growing it's growing
this works you didn't necessarily one
that excite right when the show here's
the money
here's some advice from me I'll fulfill
my obligation now you build a business
at the back end that don't cause me any
aggro and then he's supported by a team
of you know the team that you got when
you were with him was his empty
it's a cistern ft the accountant and the
secretary write what an accountants
known for being conservative right then
we preserve people on the planet because
they're cautious is what they have to do
you sitting in the room with Lord Sugar
a free accountant I'm an entrepreneur
I'm a creator right I'm a risk taker the
brain isn't right yeah that's just the
way that it is ya know the category of
people is different so I saw that and I
knew that and I understood it and I get
why it was well I have my own agenda
what my agenda was to go massive and I
thought what then was holding me back
everybody has a different agenda and
there's anything wrong with that what a
gender isn't a bad word why everybody
takes something from something because
they use it for something right it's
understandable it's how business works
you know if you want value and you want
to take and you want to do what you got
to do you know but your agenda is to get
more money or to make more profit or to
open new markets or to whatever it may
be everybody's got an agenda you just
need to understand it and embrace it
really cardones agenda is
go big that's what he teaches and that's
what I like and coming big isn't always
the best option you know we probably
went too big with him for too quickly
probably did but the reality is it was
either that or say to be more and it is
now especially you spent your whole
people who talk about unknown slow and
steady you don't want to scale to
quickly imagine running the business 15
years 20 years and all of a sudden
Corona has come along and what chew up
the face of the planet and you spent all
that time not risking or growing too big
ly because you were worried about going
out of business now something is just
wrong
punched you in the face and took you out
of business you know you might have had
a valuable business worth a lot of money
six months two months month ago now in
the new world you've just lost all the
wealth you've ever built in your
business because there's no value there
anymore you can't even sell the thing
because you register on your brand isn't
valuable anymore no one's gonna be in a
restaurant for god knows how long
right yeah and it may never come back
hospitality might be gone in the world
that we know deliver ooh
uber eats you know that's dried fruit
didn't take away that's where the world
is so just know cuz I heard I mean like
Tai Lopez again he's doing really really
well he's got an online business yeah he
is now at the moment sort of not
bragging but he's saying I said this was
gonna happen you know on lines the way
forward everything should be on line and
whilst I think he's got a good point
hard methinks but the thing is Tai and
everybody that's saying this you you
don't know what could happen it could be
that the internet goes down you've only
got an online business and you've not
got bricks and mortar business you
stuffed like yeah it's got a diversify
little and I don't think you can put all
your eggs in one basket or say or even
think that you're bulletproof because
there's some risk associated with
business hundred percent you know the
eggs in one basket thing is definitely
not the way to go and I had all of mine
in in front because I was just so
focused on building it but you do that
based on a really positive outcome and
how I expected to show that business 50
million you know is whatever deluded
world I lived in that's why I expected
when I was growing it
you know when you annoy you associate
national with huge values but the
reality is it's not that way all of the
time it isn't that black and white in
business
regrets or been any mistakes that you
look back on and say that was a mistake
no because now I'm is so much a better
person for it
if I hadn't effed up right then how
could I go and coach businesses and tell
them what not to do
the real value in a coach is to help you
from making the mistakes not necessarily
tell you how to do it because most
people can succeed right quickly but
it's keeping that success and it's
stopping it from building a par is the
hard part
flip question what are the points that
you've done you've written a book what's
he calling from broke to billionaire
border and code from the classroom to
billionaire boardroom yeah cool I need
to read that yeah I've not read that
book yet by the world so you've read a
book you've been in Forbes 30 under 30
hats off you won The Apprentice the
scared of business why what's the
biggest if you had to look back and say
that was the thing that I'm most proud
of that's the thing I'm most what is it
it's a tie-up between Forbes in the
aprenden and The Apprentice Forbes is
recognized internationally and the under
30 brand and I get a lot of respect for
that and but the apprentice you know it
was just my all-time favorite it changes
some when you ask a question but that
the minute based on how excited I was
when I was speaking about the journey
again yeah it's the apprentice it really
really is it was just an incredible
moment in my life that I just so blessed
that I got to experience that you know
so you doing a bit of teaching now
you're doing that you're getting into
property yeah what's the next big
massive thing in investing is TV so I've
got a really good format for a business
show and I want to be a presenter not a
contestant I want to knock the
apprentice off it's 9 p.m. slot maybe
see one with this new show and so I want
to get back I miss the I miss that I've
missed the attention I don't mind saying
that I'm not you know I don't think
I'm honest so you even respect now you
think I'm a dick from it regardless
right I'm always straight with people I
miss attention I loved it
I've got it just for the ego I just
loved it it was good you know people
filmmakers movie stars musicians and
they like being on stage I like being on
stage I like performing I like being in
front of people so I want to get back on
TV and I want to write a couple more
books and I want to grow internationally
now you know my folk I've done the UK
I've conquered this island in one
industry now I want something that can
have in every continent yeah I've done
so much so I've got to have something
big to feed my ambition because when I
was growing it because about begin the
2019 when I said I'm gonna commit to
imprint out right I'm gonna scale this
national or I'm gonna you know or
imagine I'll just quit so I stopped
podcasting stopped social media I
stopped socializing and I got basically
because of what I wanted to do just
focus 18 hours a day on this business
and it might you're wrongly it worked
for the company but it killed off
everything that I loved them was
passionate about yeah yeah got me proper
depressed and now I want to focus on
something again that excites my soul
what does if it's not about how much
money you make it's about how what the
kind of life that you lead and I think
me I've made a lot of money I've got a
lot of money for me if I make if I make
a hundred million next year or if I make
just a million next year what my actual
life isn't going to be much different
I'm just don't understand the salary I
live in a decent house I've got a nice
car I go on nice holidays for me it's
not about how much you can like make any
more it's good to make money but it's
about what kind of life my living if I'm
making a lot of money but I'm not doing
what I'm enjoying every day and that's
that's that's a lose-lose for me if I'm
living an exciting life I'm inspiring
people I'm happy then then that's great
and success and failure are not two
different things excess and foul you go
together the person that fails the most
will probably succeed the most as well
yeah brew failure I agree value is just
not doing anything not true factories I
didn't
any risk I didn't I didn't have any
businesses I didn't have to ever fire
anybody I didn't have to ever that's
true failure I just lived an average
life I got paid seven pounds fifty an
hour and I complained and watched you
stand us and little oh yeah you know not
having mistakes and things and like you
know so I think I mean how do you know
again you're not older than me then I
know I'm allowed
they're going for my exercise yeah I
mean I want to go internationally I
think it's fun you know money and
material objects just become by the way
science what I want to order the thing
for me personally to gets me out of bed
now he's having a big goal like growing
internationally if it makes a billion 10
billion a trillion or a quid but I still
want not quit but more than that but you
know I want to go international because
I need to have something that gets me
excited again that I may never achieve
but I'd like to helping people on an
international scale no I just want to
help as many people in every country but
can replicate what I do in two different
languages and go personal development
every state that's where I'm at you know
that's where I'm at but I do think and
as you're saying which is something that
I've learned very recently it's about
the giving back the fulfillment the
excitement we just launched something
called the Big Brother's programme which
is basically about support in 11 to 18
year old young lads that don't have a
father figure so they will join like a
young person's mentor in a mastermind
group where I will coach them well we'll
bring in other figures to come in and
coach them and basically just give them
some guidance
most people go wrong between late in
like guys like that like me when I was
growing up most of us go wrong when we
turn from 12 to 13 right and then we
don't have anybody support in our
teenage years and then you with other
older lads and so on where it can be a
bad move so adding some value showing
some of these guys that we care that's
only recently just started and that's
something that I'm gonna put my does it
I don't personally have any friends
we've entrepreneurs who were suggesting
there aren't given a lot to charity I
just think not not that I wouldn't have
a not that I would say I'm not going to
be friends but
yeah become successful if zooming that
you're a decent person
the this step that everybody takes is
how can it happen now how can I give and
you're helping people in your business
especially just like finding company
like you will now setting up I've got a
training company I help people in my
training company I'm helping people with
what provide an accommodation to people
helping people I'm helping your calling
another but actually just giving with
nothing like no business no no exchange
just because it makes you feel good and
because you can uh when you've got the
money to do that and if not even when
you've got the money to do that I
personally would encourage every single
listener even if you're not got much
money to give something because I think
that when you when you when you think
constantly inward what can I achieve
what can I do how can I be sure haven't
I iiiiii that doesn't actually bring
fulfillment but when you start actually
looking outward and looking at who you
can help Albert Einstein says don't try
and be successful try and be valuable
but success yeah and I think that brings
true fulfillment I disagree and you know
there comes a time where it does you
know as you keep saying that it doesn't
matter what you get what you make that
the only thing that you can do is to
help other people you know you have to
have something more than just focusing
on making cash you have to have
something more than and I'd suggest that
people pick something that they want to
give back on you know when I got that I
put the Big Brother program out and so
just medium why aren't you doing it with
girls as well why are you just doing it
with boys because I've chosen to target
that market because I can add value and
help them so you don't have to you know
don't necessarily try and give to
everybody why people pick and champion
their charities for a reason and it has
a deep meaning where you can emotionally
connect as well I think that's an
important one so you can understand the
people that you're trying to help if
you've been homeless help homeless
people yeah if you vanish it upbringing
help youngsters with a [ __ ] upbringing
you know whatever I we stayed in touch
with any of the of the contestants on
The Apprentice
yeah without a doubt yeah if Gary was
like my best buddy on there and we still
got a class of 2015 on on whatsapp a
group where all the lads are in there
and the girl you keep that's great did
you still watch The Apprentice no no I
had like a weird emotional disconnect
from it
because it was such a like a immense oh
and what super series after my and then
the second series kind of and then I
just got to a point where every time I
heard it we just bring back that memory
and like I don't know I've got this
weird thing where once I've done
something I don't like to revisit too
much you know I like to remember it for
what it was but I don't live in the past
so I always think about forwards like I
don't know I had a strange way that I
couldn't watch it cause it brought back
too many good memories really and it's I
don't know I didn't really want do you
know what I mean
yeah yeah yeah I know you mean I know
you mean it what about like looking back
I mean what was it like receiving
sitting down with Lord Sugar having him
as a business mentor like what was what
was that like
it's quite a more than like pinch
yourself moment is this actually real
you know the first time you went to the
board meeting after all the show and
there's no cameras it's like damn look
this is actually happening right now and
you know thing you just you think that
for a moment but then you also
automatically take it and you stride and
you know I was very focused and it's
business and so you know I was just
trying to learn as much as I could and
like look learning every element
learning here means mannerisms how we
spoke how board room etiquette should be
how you should act it when speak when
they're the right times you know the
things that you do and the things that
you don't do you know just take as much
value from everything as possible
mmm that's awesome that's awesome so let
me ask you one last question what would
be your advice to some what in this
young person wanting to be successful in
business in property as an entrepreneur
what should they do what are the steps
for the best piece of advice you give
them so into an industry that you know
some think about and if you don't know
about it get trained before you start
associate and passion is very very
important because when times get hard it
makes you it will take you through that
because it's more than just doing the
job and don't wait get started you need
to do things now the reason that I am
successful because I take action when
the time is when it comes to mind I
don't think about things too long and
believe in yourself you know you must
believe in yourself first and foremost
before anybody will believe in you you
know you can't go and get investment you
can't go on selling idea you can't go
out there and win if you don't believe
that you can so make sure you back
yourself 100% and set your goals big
don't set them to average levels you're
gonna limit where you can actually go
and you know just dream bigger than
you've ever imagined finally so this
value that is don't blame your
circumstances and don't make excuses
right lots of people have bad lives
and there's a lots of bad things that
happen to people and as much as it's
horrible and as much it's not nice you
can even sit there and make excuses or
you can use that to motivate you and
change your future for the positive
that's really really powerful Joseph
it's been an honor having you on the
show I'm sure you'll come back on
another day and all the best in what
you're doing keep up the great work and
you too buddy thanks mate I'll see you
soon